[Musique]
septembre 2010 est une série de cyclones
dévastateurs balaye les antilles à saint
martin avec des pointes à 360 kilomètres
heure irma pulvérise tous les records et
devient le cyclone le plus puissant
jamais enregistré sur l'île quelques
jours plus tard un second super aura
gants frôle le sud de la guadeloupe sur
ces îles les habitants calfeutrés chez
eux tentent de survivre mais les
cyclones détruisent tout sur leur
passage
à saint martin le jour d'après au milieu
de ce champ de ruines les habitants
relève pourtant la tête
un défi sans commune mesure s'annonce
reconstruire un territoire dévasté
quelques jours après la catastrophe
l'état met en place un important
dispositif d'urgence sur l'île
[Musique]
emmanuel macron se rend au chevet de
saint-martin et prend le soir même de sa
visite des engagements ambitieux nous
allons faire le maximum pour que cette
reconstruction se fasse vite et dans les
meilleures conditions
je les dis je bousculeraient les
procédures en guadeloupe après le
passage de maria le gouvernement promet
des aides mais déjà une autre question
se pose pour les élus comment
reconstruire ces îles en particulier en
zone littorale
là où les phénomènes sont les plus
violents deux mois après le passage d'un
mât et de marjah
nous avons pu suivre au plus près les
acteurs de la reconstruction
[Musique]
sénateur de guadeloupe sénateur de saint
martin
[Musique]
préfet en charge de la reconstruction
président de la collectivité de
saint-martin
charge à eux aujourd'hui de repenser le
futur de ces îles
[Musique]
à oriente b à saint martin il y encore
quelques semaines les plus beaux
établissements touristiques s'étendait à
perte de vue
irma à raser ce lieu pour tenter
essentielle
l'île est aujourd'hui privé d'un de ses
poumons économique la réserve d'accord
vous rencontrer là je fais le tour de
toutes les zones dites vulnérables pour
rencontrer chaque fois comme vous des
gens qui habitent qui et c'est donc là
le bâtiment d'habitation avait évoqué
tout ça a morflé
il ya seulement deux mois philip guston
n'avait encore jamais mis les pieds à
saint martin nommé au lendemain de la
catastrophe déléguée interministérielle
à la reconstruction
ce haut fonctionnaire a désormais acquis
une connaissance quasi encyclopédique de
cette île des antilles françaises depuis
la mi septembre
il multiplie les rencontres enchaîne les
visites il veut rencontrer un maximum
d'interlocuteurs
ce jour là le préfet a rendez vous avec
plusieurs hôteliers et restaurateurs de
l'île vous ce que vous voudriez c'est à
voir quelque chose au moins une armature
en dur quand on pouvoir après mettre
dessus mais ça ressemblera ce était
d'accord ok d'accord intérieure devrait
dans les habitations au rez-de-chaussée
ici vous avez du restaurant la plage
qu'on puisse se payer qu'elles soient
nettoyés et
une restauration sur la plage etc et
l'eau et bien sûr l'eau l'électricité la
clim
moi mon credo c'est l'économie réelle
concrètement pas être dans une logique
d'assistanat complet parce que sinon on
va faire crever complètement l'économie
10 et le tourisme il faut que ça il faut
que ça fonctionne rôle de l'état c'est
de porter à la connaissance de la
collectivité
les risques et des aléas donc là et
l'équipe qui est venu qui a fait le tour
de tout
les zones à aller fall et un fort pour
regarder l'impact peut dire non là la
variable d'ajustement c'est après la
qualité du bâti
c'est dire comment est ce qu'on fait en
sorte qu'on minimise le risque par des
questions purement commenté
saint martin c'est une minuscule île de
90 kilomètres carrés le territoire
européen le plus à l'ouest de la planète
à 7000 kilomètres de la métropole et 250
km de la guadeloupe
lille est découpé entre côté français et
territoire autonome rattachée aux pays
bas ici on pensait être habitué aux
tempêtes tropicales et aux cyclones mais
la puissance diament a surpris tout le
monde
[Musique]
l'ouragan a laissé lille à genoux est
révélé au passage d'importantes
fractures sociales
car à côté des luxueux établissement
touristique
il y a à saint-martin d'importants défis
économiques et sociaux pression
migratoire chômage de masse et
inégalités patente à sandy ground dans
les quartiers les plus sensibles de
lille une figure bien connue mène sa
propre inspection
depuis 2014 guyomard neil est l'unique
sénateur de saint martin continuer à
remplir un petit peu dans l'ensemble
parce que je crois
[Musique]
c'est l'une des régions qui a été le
l'afrique touchés avec quartier
d'orléans qu'on visitera tout à l'heure
population fortement défavorisés une
un habitat très diffus très variés
à c
symptomatique pas symptomatique m'a
assez révélateur de type de société dans
lequel vous vivez bien évidemment
j'étais pas assurés dont ingres et ça
c'est encore une grosse difficulté si
moi j'ai tout perdu j'ai tout perdu six
mois je peux venir voir ces deux volets
[Musique]
jette un oeil sur ma voiture j'avais vu
sa télévision
mais voilà maintenant là c'était quelque
chose qui te vraiment moi j'ai une maman
venez voir mon bureau un peu qu'on
voyait un peu commencé ce que c'est lui
qui organise une escarre ayissi bis cus
une figure incontournable c'est martin 1
et donc voilà tous les souvenirs là tout
dépend si l on vous dit que l'oréal et
toutes les parties a dit je me dis mais
pas des deux entrées moins d'eau dans
nos murs ou là comme la plupart de nous
c'est maintenant on n'est pas assuré
ça c'est une difficulté assez du jeu
donc moi j'espère monsieur le sénateur
vous qui êtes là est ce qui va avoir une
aide pour nous qu'est-ce qui fait
l'objet de ce qu'on est en train de
faire c'est de de donner le maximum
d'informations à l'état pour qu'ils
comprennent que les la situation et papa
amplifié de façon exagérée mais c'est
que c'est vraiment la réalité
les gens sont dans la détresse mais il
faut que la solidarité nationale
puissent jouer pleinement à tout cas
merci pour la visite guidée et puis mon
rouages
merci
alors nous arrivons dans une zone où
on voit aussi des constructions très
très très précaire
ne répondant strictement aucune norme
mais bon on peut pas laisser non plus
les gens dans la rue et c'est ça la
difficulté aussi aux élus c'est de faire
respecter la réglementation en même
temps et permettent pas ce qui
daisy qui est pas de gens sans trois et
c'est pas toujours très très évident
alors bien entendu y pas question qu'on
laisse reconstruire à l'identique mais
at on les moyens de nos ambitions
également on va essayer de de ce fruit
un petit chemin
on a en a un à quasiment les pieds dans
l'eau si on s'arrête à cette bordure là
pourquoi pas mais quand il ya des
avancées comme ça aussi ce sont des
situations où les gens se mettent
volontairement ou en tout cas
inconsciemment en difficulté toutes les
maisons là qui sont derrière vous et
qu'on voit à perte de vue
oui ça vous en pensez quoi vous
c'est difficile à dire c'est ce dont je
parlais de responsabilité collective
responsabilités partagées
on a laissé faire certains ont
certainement des permis peut-être mais
très certainement la bonne majorité n'en
a pas et c'est là où je pense que les
élus ont péché par manque de sévérité ou
manque de
le volonté de réglementer ou en tout cas
de faire respecter la réglementation
mais je suis prêt à prendre toute ma
part dans ce travail pédagogique et je
reste persuadé que ma population est une
population qui est capable de comprendre
dès lors qu'elle est associée aux choix
et aux difficultés
beau
où
irma a causé la mort de 11 personnes à
saint martin 95% des habitations ont été
frappée par le cyclone
les quelques maisons encore intacte font
figure de miraculés
ce jour là c'est cette habitation
épargné par l'ouragan qui intéresse
particulièrement le préfet gustin
bonjour attend de vous rencontrer
merci de m'accueillir chez vous on a une
des zones de toits plats entre les
charpentes et s'est inspiré en fait des
casavant qui étaient les constructions
traditionnelles de saint barth d'accord
y'a pas des bords de toi d'accord mais
si celle ci si le vent s'engouffre son
accord que servir potentiellement de
fusible entre guillemets en fait mais
les ouvertures côté mer était protégé
par les systèmes en contreplaqué comme
ça
la baie vitrée de repenser à châssis
fixe forcément c'est plus stable
c'est un verre québec comme ça c'est un
verre trois plis c'est l'état sont plus
là est éthiquement mais je pense que ça
peut protéger la piscine était remplie
d'arbres comme ça de tasseaux en boitant
et tous à voler dans les vagues donc
quand bien même c'est
et c'est solide où on peut pas en parler
faisait tout à l'heure le parallèle avec
les vers de tgv que j'ai vu il rentre
pas ils rencontrent pas une poutre en
bois quand il roule à 370 km heure alors
que la food renvoi elle peut arriver à
cette vitesse là
un aspect intéressant dans cette
rencontre ici c'est la question des
matériaux qu'on utilise pour la
construction s'est pas seulement la
question des matériaux c'est la manière
aussi dont on utilise les matériaux est
vraiment à la mise en place et c'est que
c'est fondamental
concrètement il ya eu des erreurs de
conception qui peuvent être récurrente
et qu'on retrouve dans la standard de
qualité qu'on retrouve sur les
constructions d'ici après ce qui va être
surtout important et je crois que
monsieur a employé les mêmes termes que
j'emploie tout le temps c'est que on
tire quand même les leçons de ce qui
s'est passé donc un exemple comme cette
maison était pour moi vraiment
fondamental de se dire que voilà des
maisons résistent aussi parce que les
choses sont faites correctement et a
contrario
on a des maisons qui sont au tapis parce
que les choses n'avaient pas été faites
correctement mineur si vraiment pour cet
échange s'est pressée sens
habitat précaire en zone dangereuse
multiples défauts dans la construction
des édifices dans tous les secteurs de
l'île cet ouragan a provoqué une prise
de conscience
regardez les constructions
et ça ce sont des constructions
publiques la salle omnisports ensuite
vous avez la centrale edf vous avez lu
usine de production d'eau donc tous
toutes ces constructions sont en bordure
littorale aussi et donc si nos aigles
s'applique pour le particulier ça doit
s'appliquer aussi
les pouvoirs publics à sandy ground
l'école aline ans on a été construite
entre l'océan et le lagon il ya des
écoles qui ont peut-être été construite
à des endroits dangereux ou même si
elles sont encore en état sont des zones
qui sont pas forcément pensé pour des
écoles
oui tout à fait c'est une question qui
interpelle et je ne veux pas non plus
mes clips ses jets d'un responsable
politique au niveau local pendant quatre
ans j'ai j'ai piloté l'aménagement du
territoire donc j assume une part de
responsabilité mais c'est une succession
d'erreurs collectives co dont on voit
aujourd'hui les conséquences 1 et il
faut de mon point de vue il faut
maintenant qu'on réfléchisse tous un
collectivement aux nouvelles solutions
apportées c'est vrai que le territoire
n'est pas extensible à l'infini le font
si rares mais je pense que certains
choix mérite d'être revu et corrigé
offert
depuis quelques jours dans cette école
la vie reprend petit à petit et toi
allez ici l'académie organise un système
d pour accueillir les enfants de l'école
maternelle voisine car leur
établissement était trop endommagée pour
réouvrir bon je vais pas être très
original on sait que irma ça a été
quelque chose d'extraordinaire et
exceptionnels comme cyclone j'ai été
également traumatisés donc ça a été un
déchirement de voir que vont ils étaient
meurtris et blessé et devoirs des
personnes proches également qu'ils ont
souvent tout perdu
certaines qui ont perdu la vie
[Musique]
devenu un symbole de la puissance dire
main la préfecture dévastée de lille
fait figure de ruines abandonnées
[Musique]
depuis deux mois les services de l'état
sont réunis ailleurs le centre de
commandement a été improvisée dans un
autre bâtiment plus récent de marigot
tous les services de l'état travaillent
ici dans ce qui était jusqu'au passage
du cyclone
le pôle emploi de saint martin c'est ici
que le préfet gustin multiplie ses
rendez-vous représentants du monde
économique anciens élus locaux mais
aussi parlementaires représentant en
tout cas ce jour là le préfet et le
sénateur se rencontrent pour la première
fois je vous en prie asseyez-vous la cie
vont en tout cas merci monsieur le
sénateur d'avoir trouvé le le temps
n'avait pas réussi à se voir à paris
c'est plus facile de venir se se voir à
saint martin seront pour vous que pour
moi alors je souhaitais que les choses
se fassent confiance en concertation il
faut revenir un petit peu à la genèse et
comprendre on ne pourra pas que oublié
ou contraindre le particulier appliqué
les rênes de construction d'urbanisme et
des lois en vigueur surtout s'agissant
du littoral six mois même temps qu on
les transgresse un certain nombre
d'établissements publics ici ont été
construites sans permis
l'office du tourisme certaines ont des
cols aussi on a eu les problèmes à
l'école le cul de sac qui a été
construit sur un terrain qu'il était
d'ailleurs qu'il est morte
donc les écoles de cul-de-sac sens
aujourd'hui
ok
la collectivité est compétente depuis
2007 elle a sa part de responsabilité
j'en assume pleinement puisque j'ai
animé ce territoire dans snow même de
2014 à 2017 avec les difficultés que
j'ai connues lorsque j'ai voulu mettre
en place le psg lorsque je refusais les
permis de construire etc alors
l'exiguïté du territoire et la proximité
ou là la connaissance de tout un chacun
amplifie le problème mais je crois qu'il
faut profiter aujourd'hui ont tiré leçon
en tirer les leçons des humains et de se
dire effectivement lille n'est pas d'une
grande superficie
respectons le type de construction les
normes en vigueur
alors je sais que il y aura une
conséquence il a une conséquence font
forcément électorale puisque quand on
touche aux particuliers ont touché un
réservoir de voix mais bon sommes nous
prêts à la chose est claire et nette
l'état ne peut pas se substituer à cette
collectivité tout il y a près un échelon
ultérieure il revient à l'état qui
exercent
le contrôle de légalité de veiller aussi
derrière parce que ben les documents en
particulier les permis de construire
soit conforme au document d'urbanisme
une chose qui ne m'était rappelle quand
même et je crois que oui on ne pourra
pas faire l'économie de cela c'est la
vérification de l'effectivité de la
prise en compte des normes
donc il faut avoir véritablement ce
contrôle aussi à pau c'est oui ou même
pas possible parce que à penser oui
peut-être c'est déjà trop tard en cours
le pardon c'est le sénateur d'être comme
un terme qui a sans doute choquée mais
ça s'appelle une police de l'urbanisme
qui sera bien fait mais concrètement
qu'on aime voilà des contrôles a
posteriori qu'on ait un contrôle aussi
par rapport à un cadastre est pas encore
un hit la connaissance qu'on peut avoir
du bâti pour voir s'ils ne se construit
pas des choses qui auraient pas dû être
construite souvent sans permis de
construire est très clair donc ça ça
suppose là vraiment la mise en place
d'une vraie structure de contrôle qui
aujourd'hui il faut bien constater
l'équation de la reconstruction est
complexe
initialement prévue début novembre le
rapport de philippe gustin commandé par
le gouvernement est resté finalement
confidentiel car le sujet est très
délicat notamment entre l'état et la
collectivité d'outre-mer
ok il ya une difficulté à laquelle moi
je suis confronté et souvent c'est que
lorsque les choses vont bien à l'état
nous embêtait avec leurs normes
européennes et dans la caraïbe et c est
quand il ya une catastrophe mais que
fait l'état l'état
il faut avoir une cohérence vue et soit
on appartient entièrement il en nation
comme la france il ya forcément des
idées des très bonnes choses il ya
forcément aussi quelques contraintes
mais où est-ce qu'ils avalent contre
tous les systèmes bien les contres
liberté on voit les au revoir
[Musique]
après le passage du cyclone hier main
les représentants de saint-martin
s'attendait à un important effort
financier la part de la métropole
aujourd'hui les premiers fonds d'urgence
sont mises en place mais les
négociations sur l'urbanisme se
multiplient
[Musique]
l'état entend superviser la
reconstruction de très près de quoi
échauder les élus locaux car depuis 2007
ses compétences d'aménagement du
territoire appartiennent à la
collectivité locale daniel gibbs préside
le conseil territorial de saint-martin
et il veut aller vite adopté début
novembre une délibération permet à
toutes les maisons détruites par rma
d'être reconstruite à l'identique à
condition d'avoir eu un permis de
construire mais un sujet reste en
suspens que faire des habitations de
bord de mer
aujourd'hui toute la discussion est
basée sur le fait de savoir si on va
reconstruire ou pas son littoral et si
on reconstruisait de quelle manière on
va reconstruire
donc ce sont des questions qu'il faut
répondre en urgence pourquoi parce qu'il
ya des gens qui attendent pour
reconstruire il ya des gens qui sont
sans domicile
il ya des gens qui sont dans la tente
d'avoir les instructions claires et
précises donc nous sommes en train de
travailler sur ces deux volets avec avec
les services de l'état et chacun encore
une fois dans son domaine de compétence
et je suis prêt si là dessus parce que
la collectivité n'a aucunement
l'intention de laisser ses domaines de
compétence à quelqu'un d'autre
il n'en demeure pas moins que nous
sommes en partenariat avec l'état mais
ce partenariat il a deux facettes la
facette je suis compétent je décide dans
mon domaine de compétence
ils sont compétents sur le celui de
l'environnement idée si dans leurs
compétences mais nous travaillons
ensemble pour arriver à quelque chose
qui soit intelligente maintenant
des quartiers entiers il faut qu'on
discute sur le fait que vous pourrez pas
vous réinstaller là bien sûr mais moi je
les dis je suis prêt à prendre tous les
risques
je suis prêt à prendre politique je suis
prêt à prendre tout le courage qu'il
faut pour dire les choses qu'on ne veut
plus tard peut-être par entendre parce
que c'est pour l'intérêt de l'être
humain c'est l'intérêt quand j'ai
toujours dit je ne donnerai pas de
permis de construire qui sont des permis
de mourir voilà cesser les termes sont
bien choisis et sont forts parce que
c'est ça qu'il s'agit mais de façon
raisonnée tout l'enjeu des ans mais
concerne ses bâtiments situés en zone
littorale dans des zones très précises
on s'apprête donc à négocier avec l'état
de nouvelles normes urbanistiques ces
ouragans ce sont de véritables défis
pour les élus locaux
un sentiment partagé à 200 km au sud de
saint martin la guadeloupe c'est un
autre les territoires balayés récemment
par un phénomène cyclonique
ici c'est maria qui a tout saccagé sur
son passage
dominique théophile est l'un des trois
sénateurs de la guadeloupe
deux mois après le cataclysme il est
toujours frappé par l'intensité du
phénomène
[Musique]
à chaque passage d'un ouragan c'est la
carte de la guadeloupe qui est redessiné
le poulailler
oulala ainsi un petit bout c'est tout un
pan de la falaise d'un gilles qui s'est
décroché le soin du passage de maria
d'une plaque est parti donc où nous
sommes aujourd'hui il suffirait qu'ils
s'y chrono est un pays où il faut de
fortes pluies
on peut se retrouver avec pratiquement
six mètres qui passe on voit plus de 10
mètres de falaise on était complètement
éliminés puisque cet espace vide
autrefois c'était de la terre me fait
d'ailleurs tout le long du littoral
les différents résidait j'avais le
jardin enfin cultiver les produits fins
des ignames tomates et autres de cette
coque
il y a beaucoup de maisons qui sont
pratiquement sans thème ferme au dessous
qui sont cocody qui suspendu suspendu
c'est de la responsabilité de l'état en
sept parties
la zone est donc vous savez l'état est à
la fois près de nous mais aussi loin de
nous donc c'est à nous de pouvoir
ramener l'état et à ses responsabilités
mais il faut les relais et c'est ce que
je suis en train de dire il faut déjà
que les dossiers soit ficelé ça toi
reconnu les charges aux parlementaires
de pouvoir rappeler des obligations
d'état aussi pour accompagner les
collectivités puisque là on sent qu'il
ya une urgence il y a
vraiment c'est la sécurité qui est en
jeu 5 à 10 à dangereux vent violent flux
abondante inondations en guadeloupe la
puissance des phénomènes a surpris même
à l'intérieur des terres
ici c'est un canal qui a débordé
réveillant ses habitants au milieu de la
nuit
même les voisins là haut ils souhaitent
une ou des et si tu veux mon pire que
nous parce que eux ils sont vraiment
plus bas que nous et c'était
catastrophique
si les yeux étaient fermées par le passé
je pense qu'il faut les ouvrir grand
puisqu'il ne s'agit pas simplement de
laisser passer auquel ou tel dossier
pour un administré il s'agit de la
sécurité des personnes sur tout et est
donc on peut pas jouer avec ça il faut
être ferme sur les constructions qui
sont trop près du lit
du passage de l'eau parce que il s'agit
pas de faire vu dire design il s'agit de
faire dans le durable il s'agit de
protéger les uns et les autres
donc il faut être très ferme là dessus
et c'est un signal qu'on doit faire
passer en temps qui est venu ce qui se
produit ici
mais bon là il faut non seulement
corriger mais éviter que se reproduisent
pas les mêmes irma et maria deux
cyclones qui ont marqué les habitants de
saint martin et de la guadeloupe
mais au delà c'est toute l'opinion
publique qui a été frappé par les images
de ces ouragans avec des phénomènes
climatiques d'une intensité inégalée
jusqu'aujourd'hui
chacun s'interroge comment organiser une
meilleure résilience de ces territoires
et éviter que tout ce qui est
reconstruit aujourd'hui ne soit à
nouveau souffler en quelques heures dans
les prochaines années
[Musique]